SO I SPEAK FOR ALL GAMERS WHEN I
SAY THE
MEDIA SHOULD STOP TALKING TO
CRITICS LIKE ANITA SARKEESIAN.
HERE NOW TO BE TALKED TO IS
MEDIA CRITIC AND CREATOR
OF THE WEB SERIES FEMINIST
FREQUENCY, ANITA SARKEESIAN
[APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT, LOOK.
LET'S PUT THIS ON THE LINE,
OKAY.
LET'S CALL THIS WHAT IT IS.
YOU AND THE OTHER FEMI-NAZIS
IN THE GAMER WORLD ARE COMING
FOR A BALLS TO CUT EM OFF AND
PUT THEM INTO A LITTLE FELT
PURSE AND TAKE THEM AWAY SO WE
HAVE TO PLAY YOUR NON-VIOLENT
GAMES, RIGHT.
>> NO. THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> IT'S A CULTURE WAR. IT'S A
SUBCULTURE WAR.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING GOING
ON, AND WHAT IT IS IS WOMEN
BEING HARASSED AND THREATENED
AND TERRORIZED.
>> AFTER YOU FIRST ATTACKED
GAMERS AFTER ENJOYING LOOKING
AT BIG BREASTED WOMEN WITH TINY
ARMOR THAT BARELY COVERS THEIR
NIPPLES. WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THAT? I LIKE WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. I'M A MAN BABY, NEWS
FLASH, I LIKE IT.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THAT
IS IT ACTUALLY REINFORCES THE
CULTURE MYTH THAT WOMEN ARE
SEXUAL OBJECTS AND SEXUAL PLAY
THINGS FOR MALE AMUSEMENT AND
WE'RE NOT.
>> Stephen: WE'RE SAVING
THEM. THEY'RE DAMSELS IN
DISTRESS.
I'M SAVING THE PRINCESS.
AM I SUPPOSED TO LET THE
PRINCESS DIE? IS THAT WHAT YOU
WANT.
THAT'S KINDA HARSH, THAT'S KINDA
HOSTILE.
>> MAYBE THE PRINCESS COULDN'T
BE A DAMSEL AND SHE COULD SAVE
HERSELF.
[CROWD CHEERING]
>> Stephen: THEY'VE GOT GAMES.
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU BROUGHT A
POSSE.
>> I'M WELL LIKED.
>> Stephen: SO YOU'VE BEEN THE
OBJECT OF CRITICISM YOURSELF.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: WHAT HAPPENED AT
UTAH STATE UNIVERSITY.
>> THERE WAS A THREAT THAT
SOMEONE E-MAILED TO THE SCHOOL
SAYING THAT THEY WOULD COMMIT
THE BIGGEST SCHOOL SHOOTING, A
MASSACRE IF I WAS ALLOWED TO
SPEAK.
>> Stephen: BY CRITICIZING
THESE, YOU SAY WOULD YOU CALL
THEM MALE FANTASY GAMES OR MALE
FANTASY OBJECTIFICATION OF WOMEN
GAMES.
>> SOME OF THEM.
>> Stephen: GIVE ME SOME
NAMES.
NAME SOME NAMES.
>> SO IN THE WORK THAT I DO, I
LOOK AT HUNDREDS OF EXAMPLES OF
VIDEO GAMES.
>> Stephen: CAN YOU THINK OF 3?
>> I CAN BUT IT'S A BIGGER ISSUE
TO TALK ABOUT THE INDUSTRY AS A
WHOLE AND HOW IT PERPETUATES
THESE IDEAS OF SEXISM AND
MISOGYNY AS OPPOSED TO GRAND
THEFT AUTO FOR EXAMPLE.
>> Stephen: WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT WOMEN ARE BEING THREATENED.
IT'S ALMOST ENTIRELY WOMEN WHO
ARE BEING THREATENED IN GAMER
GATES.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: CHRIS KLUWE HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS, OTHER MEN
HAVEN'T BEEN THREATENED.
WHY DO YOU THINK WOMEN ARE BEING
THREATENED IN THIS EXCHANGE.
>> I THINK WOMEN ARE PERCEIVED
AS THREATENING BECAUSE WE'RE
ASKING FOR GAMES TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE.
WE'RE ASKING FOR GAMES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE EXIST AND WE
LOVE GAMES.
>> Stephen: WHY NOT HAVE A
SEPARATE GAME.
HAVE SEPARATE BUT EQUAL GAMES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WELL WE DO HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF GAMES.
>> Stephen: WHAT ARE YOU
COMPLAINING ABOUT.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS WE HAVE
THIS WIDE RANGE OF GAME THAT
WE'RE SEEING MOBILE GAMES, WE'RE
SEEING INDY GAMES, WE'RE SEEING
THIS INFLUX OF DIFFERENT KIND OF
GAMES AND THAT'S WHAT GAMERGATE
IS RESPONDING TO.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY RESPONDING TO
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE SAYING
GAMING CAN NO LONGER BE THIS
LITTLE BOY'S CLUB ANYMORE.
MANY OF US WOMEN HAVE BEEN
PLAYING GAMES OUR WHOLE LIVES.
SO THEY'RE LASHING OUT BECAUSE
WE'RE CHALLENGING THE STATUS QUO
OF GAMING AS A MALE DOMINATED
SPACE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Stephen: YOU SEE.
YOU HEAR THE APPLAUSE FOR THE
IDEA OF A MALE DOMINATED SPACE.
WHAT ABOUT THE ACCUSATIONS OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN DESIGNERS,
FEMINISTS AND JOURNALISTS.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ETHICS IN
GAMER JOURNALISM.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW HUGE THAT
IS.
WHAT IF THERE WAS NO ETHICS IN
HOLLYWOOD JOURNALISM.
[LAUGHTER]
IF WE CAN'T TRUST ENTERTAINMENT
TONIGHT OR TMZ, WHERE WOULD WE
BE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT FOR GAMER
JOURNALISM.
>> I THINK THAT IS A SORT OF
COMPELLING WAY TO REFRAME THE
FACT THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY AN
ATTACK ON WOMEN.
ETHICS AND JOURNALISM IS NOT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN ANY WAY.
IT'S ACTUALLY MEN GOING AFTER
WOMEN IN REALLY HOSTILE
AGGRESSIVE WAYS.
THAT'S WHAT GAMERGATE IS ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT TERRORIZING
WOMEN FOR BEING INVOLVED IN THIS
INDUSTRY, THIS HOBBY.
>> Stephen: OFF SUBJECT, BUT AS
A MAN, AM I ALLOWED TO BE A
FEMINIST.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WOMEN
SHOULD HAVE EQUAL RIGHTS TO
MEN AND WE SHOULD FIGHT FOR
THOSE RIGHTS.
>> Stephen: SURE.
>> GREAT, THEN YOU'RE A
FEMINIST.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Stephen: ANITA SARKEESIAN,
FEMINIST FREQUENCY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.